Congress has formally approved the
first-ever impeachment investigation of
a president running for re-election
House lawmakers voted yesterday pretty
much along party lines to proceed to a
new phase the most serious allegation
says president Trump withheld military
aid to pressure Ukraine's president to
investigate Democrats the White House
calls the entire process of blatantly
partisan attempt to destroy the
president Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with more on this story so Nancy
what is the next step look like well
this vote Gale paves the way for the
first nationally televised impeachment
hearings in 21 years they could get
underway in mid-november but the
schedule is still fluid now Republicans
had demanded this vote but they all
voted no saying that they and the
president don't get enough rights are we
done
is the president impeach no but thank
you for asking
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi stopped by
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert on
the heels of an historic House vote what
happened today was a it was a
continuation of our inquiry that we have
but just set forth the rules of
procedure for how we go forward now when
do public hearings start
they'll be soon could you be vaguer
for now closed-door depositions continue
with the president's top Russia adviser
Tim Morrison telling lawmakers yesterday
that he went straight to White House
lawyers after President Trump asked his
Ukrainian counterpart to investigate Joe
Biden Morrison said he was not concerned
that anything illegal was discussed but
he did worry that such an investigation
might affect the bipartisan support our
Ukrainian partners currently experience
in Congress in an interview with The
Washington Examiner mr. Trump called the
testimony fantastic
Republicans agrees I look forward to the
American people getting to getting to
see what he had what he had to say House
Intelligence chair Adam Schiff told CBS
News anchor and managing editor Norah
O'Donnell that only classified and
personal information will be redacted
from the deposition transcripts but I
think as soon as
next week we'll be able to start
releasing transcripts Republicans will
have the right to propose their own
witnesses for public hearings though
Democrats can override them they don't
really want to get to the truth they
want to remove a sitting president mr.
Trump's lawyers will get the chance to
cross-examine witnesses but that right
could get revoked one party to
litigation unlawfully blocks
the investigation as this president has
been doing although we hope you won't
continue doing it you may have to take
some steps so we may have to join
adverse inferences we may have to do
other things we'll see what kind of
punishments are you considering I'm not
considering anything at the moment we'll
see what it what happens Republicans say
those kinds of ambiguities only add to
the unfairness but Democrats argue that
the rules are actually quite similar to
those that govern the public impeachment
proceedings for presidents Nixon and
Clinton president Trump has come up with
a novel idea for his own defense he told
The Washington Examiner that he might
read the call summary of his
conversation with the Ukrainian
president aloud he described it Anthony
as a sort of fireside chat for
television okay Nancy thank you very
much